Hi.
Welcome to this week's episode.
Today we're going to talk about more fallen
linguistics.
Morphology is a branch of linguistics that deals with the structure and form of
the words in a language and all words can be divided into two categories,
content,
words and function words.
Content words are words that have a clear lexical,
meaning these classes composed of nouns,
verbs,
adjectives and adverbs,
their words for people,
things,
actions,
ideas and attributes.
Content words are considered an open class because new words can be added and
indeed are added to this category due to changes in technology.
We've added words such as dumb phone and blog changing.
Fashion trends have given us shootings and jeggings.
We got a new words to describe food and food eaters such as freaking food or
locavore.
Social media has given us words such as friend and tweaks and the list could go
on function where it's,
on the other hand,
do not have a clear lexical meaning,
but do serve a functional purpose in a language.
These are words such as conjunctions articles,
prepositions,
and pronouns.
Function.
Words are considered a closed class because generally speaking,
we do not make additions to this category.
When was the last time you've seen a new preposition?
Words are all around us.
We write them,
we speak.
Then we think them.
Some words are made up of one piece,
but many other words are made up of more than one piece,
more than one component,
and these components are called morphemes.
A morpheme is a minimal unit of meaning,
so while some words can consist of one more female,
thus be minimal units of meaning in and of themselves.
Most words consist of more than one morphine.
The word peace has one morpheme and thus cannot be broken down into smaller
units of meaning.
Peace full has two morphemes piece,
a state of harmony that exists during the absence of war plus full.
A suffix meaning full of something peaceful.
Lee has three morphemes piece plus full plus Lee because Lee in and of itself
holds the meaning of in the manner of so really peacefully contains three units
of meaning that when combined together give us the meaning of the word as a
whole.
Obviously words can have a lot more than three more PM's.
Antidisestablishmentarianism has a total of seven and there are words with even
more than that.
We should keep in mind that some morphine's can be used by themselves.
These are called free morphings.
They're not dependent on any other morpheme to complete their meaning.
Open class content words such as girl fish,
tree and love are all considered free morphemes as our close class function.
Words such as the and four or if other morphemes cannot be used by themselves
and dependent on other morphemes.
These are called bound morphemes and bell morphine's are further divided into
two categories.
Affixes and bound roots bound routes are routes that could not be used by
themselves.
For example,
see in received,
conceive and deceive cannot stand on its own.
I cannot see them.
Something at fixes are more things that can be added to the front of a word,
a prefix such as pre read this or [inaudible] to the end of a word,
a suffix such as an ise,
al or Lee or another lane.
We just do the middle of the word called [inaudible] or to both sides of the
word called circum fixes and epics is can be divided into two categories of
their own.
Wait,
what?
Yeah.
How about we take a moment to review.
First
morphemes are the basic units of meaning.
Morphemes can be divided into two classes,
battle more themes and free morphemes.
Free morphemes include open class content,
words such as cute dog run away and closed class function words such as the on
yet,
and he found more themes can be divided into two categories at fixes and roots
bound routes such as seed cannot be used by themselves.
Ethics is in English or the prefixes and suffixes that we add to the beginning
or ending of a word and are further divided into derivational.
Apics is and inflection and fixes
their emotional APICS is our APICS is that when added to a word,
create a new word with a new meaning.
They're called derivational.
Precisely because a new word is derived when they're added to the original word,
and many times these newly created words belong to a new grammatical category.
Some APICS is turndowns into adjectives like beauty,
too.
Beautiful.
Some change verbs into nouns like seeing to singer some change,
adjectives to adverbs,
like precise to precisely still.
Others turn nouns to verbs,
adjectives to nouns and verbs to adjectives.
Other affixes do not change the grammatical category of the word.
They're added to king.
Plus.
Dumb goes from noun to noun.
Do plus read goes from birth to verb.
Blue plus ish goes from adjective to adjective.
We use derivational.
Ethics is constantly and they're a very important part of English because they
help us to form the majority of words that exist in our language.
In English,
all of the inflectional affixes are suffixes that would add it to the end of the
word.
Don't change its meaning or at least not in any large sense.
Instead,
they change things like the person tents and number of a word.
In English,
there are a total of eight.
The third person,
singular s such as it can kills young links.
The past tense Ed such as Ron kissed her money.
The progressive ing such as Han is falling into the SARLACC pit.
The past participle een such as the emperor has fallen and cannot get up.
The plural s such as vampires make the worst boyfriends,
the possessive s such as,
that's Luke's hand,
isn't it?
The comparative Er,
such as the card is cooler than Kirk and the superman that est such as,
that's the sweetest thing I've ever seen compared to other languages.
English has very few inflectional affixes,
but they served their purpose well.
Nonetheless,
I realized that this is a lot of information.
Stay tuned for a few more videos on morphology where we'll introduce a few new
concepts and go over some of the concepts we've already covered.
How next time.